apparently Elon didn't like how many
retweets his tweet got or likes his
tweet got Joe Biden was Barry and Elon
during the Super Bowl and you know what
he did he's like Engineers I need you to
find a way to boost up my tweets if
they're not doing well that's
embarrassing is it that's some [__] boy
[__] if you're tired
[Music]
imagine you bought a house and you can't
do nothing special in it yeah but you
can't talk all this [__] about
censorship
but don't let that leak though that's
that cool like that leak bro it's
because he's got these [__] lib [__]
working at Twitter he didn't he didn't
weed them all out liberal Cooks you
think maybe they made up the story
to make Elon look bad oh are we just are
we conspiracying on top yeah did we
start with conspiracy why keep why not
why stop okay go go go go go I'll listen
first of all I don't I think if it's all
about free speech and not censoring you
gotta let that [__] Rock but also if you
see Biden's thing outperforming uh we
need to see that first it couldn't have
been good
I thought you're speaking archives
but I need to know the tweets I need to
compare them but keep going so maybe
first of all Elon maybe did have a
meeting like hey you guys need to do X Y
and Z and they didn't want to be there
on [__] Super Bowl Sunday or the
Monday morning after the Super Bowl and
like you know what we're gonna say we're
gonna say this meeting was because Elon
wants to boost his own specific Twitter
and defy all the rules he said he was
laying down when he bought it did he
ever say that though they don't like
working for him now he basically said
like we shouldn't censor we should have
free speech this is in his own way since
I have a free speeches but it's making
sure his speech is a little bit more
free yeah that's not free to me but also
also he's got Jill Biden walking kicked
up no disrespect obviously to the
president
you give her a little smooch or what
listen I'm not gonna disrespect
disrespect well you didn't know what I
was going to say did you yeah I'm not
gonna disrespect the First Lady by not
laying it on the lips if that's what she
wants if the first lady comes to me
she's from a different time bro it's a
different generation she's into the day
you used to kiss people on the lips I
saw my mom do that with a guy once yes
I didn't fight him I was too young but
she was doing a dance and it was a
choreographed dance there was a kiss at
the end of the dance I'm asking my dad I
swear to God I'm like why y'all
subjected me to this WOW burned out a
whole place down stuff
just burn it down burn it down I was
like yo you go with that we gonna swing
on this
[Laughter]
what the hell is going on they're like
oh it's the choreography I'm like how
necessary was that yeah not necessary at
all at all they would swing dancing
swing dance
at the time CGI was not a thing no CGI
just planted lips on my mom my mom got
some big lips okay
honestly now that was crazy
to my mom
all respect because I love my mom more
than anything but the lips aren't the
biggest things on her he might have
missed you know what I mean he might
have
he might have thought it was cheek
okay we could say that we could look at
it and I wish that they they told me
that instead of yeah that that was an
intentional part of the [__]
choreography yeah if anybody got
deducted points for missing in the
choreography I mean you want a good 1.0
rating we can't be missing choreography
yes that is a winner bro she's a winner
my mom's a winner that's why uh Hunter's
a crackhead what that's why Joe Biden's
kids a crackhead because his mom's
smooching everyone you can't look at
your mom tongue and down everybody
there's no family it was a peck there's
a tongue it's a peck now but back in the
day you don't know what it was oh you
think they got Morgan Services [__]
lips okay hell yeah that's traumatizing
that is [__] traumatizing Aiden Smith
he's crying now because his mom's just
going around kissing everybody
at all costs at all costs all I'm trying
to say is
what the [__]
oh yeah if if Elon Musk what's the point
of owning some [__] you can't do what
you want with it that's what I'm saying
he's not the president he's just like yo
make my [__] the first thing you see
which is completely reasonable Tom was
your first friend on Facebook that's
right no one was like oh this guy's
making everybody friends with everyone
no also it's not like he was publicly
appointed he bought the [__] so it's his
yeah we lucky we get to be on it okay
literally if you don't want us on it we
don't have to be I don't know about that
yeah we're lucky we need to say thank
you you think about this with your
apartment maybe keep going are you are
you like man I'm so lucky the landlord
this lets me you know pay to be here
have you tried to get an apartment
have you seen the anxiety that shifty's
message me at three in the [__]
morning like listen there's a shoe box
off [__] Canal Street with three reps
in it it's going for 3 500 maybe I can
go look at it I need to get an
appointment to observe it yeah
so to answer your question
Celsius gets you all the excitement and
energy none of the retention
I don't need this in my life I do
I'm trying to forgive me I said woke me
up are you going through something why
are you trying to forget everything I
mean you know trauma yeah drama
that is something you said didn't happen
yeah your mom wasn't dating he doesn't
remember you did block it enough cells
and it says you forget anything but
isn't that nice that even though your
mom was single that she just wasn't
getting her cheeks rinsed through your
whole come on
put those words in the same size even if
it's good she did no I would never say
she did because that's not true what I'm
saying is she did not get [__] snow
cats
my mom's getting packed up my mom's
getting packed up sounds nice
that doesn't happen to your mom no say
what didn't happen to his bombers I
didn't get the battering ram
[Music]
s
at least their men at least twice at
least but Al's mom wasn't getting dick
punched in her forehead
true back to a thing she wasn't getting
nothing she had too much respect for
herself to do that Mom I'm sorry Mom yo
I'm sorry she wasn't she was not she
respected you and herself
what did I say all I know is that wasn't
happening to your mom I can't even say
you know what was happening
your mom was obviously raising a family
she was okay and she wasn't getting
stretched out like Gumby
she wasn't that wasn't that was not
happening that definitely wasn't
actually definitely that's all right
that was not happening
Armstrong going on over there
your mom wasn't getting treated like
Dawson
you know what I mean
yoga flames
what I'm trying to say is that's a good
thing y'all didn't go through what I
went through having to watch your mom do
a waltz get pecked down yeah yeah you
know what I mean that's trauma Mama's
watching this right now how dare you put
me through that did she kiss you after
probably
probably whoa yeah you don't know what
this is like where did she kiss you all
your moms did nothing where'd she kiss
you though no moms didn't receive not
once Sledgehammer
you got you got another random dude
another guy on your list
my mom got at least one yeah I got at
least one I'm not saying your dad's
short dick yeah I'm not saying it yeah
you're not saying that so it's okay
cause you're not saying it I'm not
saying it yeah
that works out it's very simple I'm not
saying that at all so Biden tweets find
it could tweet whatever you want yeah
you know whatever you want if he wants
to show his wife his wife was walking
yeah slow walk too what was that it was
slow walk everything slow walk
everything's better in slow-mo uh-huh
facts as your president I'm not picking
favorites but as Jill Biden's husband
Fly Eagles Fly I hate it when oh that's
a bug that's fine you know what I
[__] hate
when like [__] downplay their
success
to be a husband
like you know like like I'm I'm not
depressed I'm Gerald Biden's husband
it's like you could only say that
because everybody knows that you're the
[__] president Oh you mean like when
you give like a Valentine's Day or happy
birthday post like look at my post look
at my post though
I'm ready for it I'm ready for it this
[__] was there writing an essay
yesterday about that's in the car oh my
car was fired and honestly she didn't
even react that much and I took it back
and I started reading it like did I
[__] misspell something I literally
took the car back from My Wife and read
it out loud like I don't think you
actually read it yeah I think you're too
distracted by the flowers that you're
not putting the time in what's up boo
okay look at this happy birthday my
everything thank you for making me the
luckiest man in the world I love you
that's fire okay he's he's identifying
as somebody's husband you can only do
that when nobody thinks that you're that
the liberal cut right so it's a flex
you're just saying it's a flex no but
he's also identifying himself as your
president he's saying fake humble he's
doing the fake humble I'm saying he
don't really think of himself like that
and he knows that he's not that
so he will present himself
as your president that's a flex he says
he's your president as your president
means I am your president I'm just not
picking aside let me try to communicate
this in another way
let me let me go ahead my heart is flex
that's why I was the top yeah
as your dad yeah as your daddy I'm not
saying this and he's saying that to Elon
no one's reading this no stay-at-home
husband is identifying as that that's
why I'm saying it's a flex
identifies as our president you
understand that right [__] all them
Shifty [__] all that I just want to let
you know from the bottom of my heart
[__] all of them you know you know
liberal cucks by the lame stream media
regulated by the lame brainwashed dude
yeah dude are you just trying to bring
comedy back that's all I'm trying to do
is [__] bring comedy back dude what
the [__] the lame stream media's
obviously got them and you know what the
cancel culture is gonna come get you one
day
that's what happens with cancer culture
that's what they're shooting down yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's gonna eat you up
it's gonna [__] eat all three of you
that is true all right so anyway I don't
think Elon did anything wrong here if he
wants to put his [__] out the front
that's fine it's yours if you pay 44
billion dollars or something you guys do
whatever the [__] you want with it this
thing in New York real estate where they
go oh you can't renovate your bathroom
without asking mayor Adams for
permission yeah this is Twitter is his
he could change the name he can do
whatever the [__] he wants do all that
then lean and go all the way go all the
way he just need better control of the
troops like that shouldn't be leaking
yeah that is true how does he do it I
mean that's probably
oh I've been reading some dictator stuff
you got to kill him out
yep you gotta Point people let that have
a little bit of power and you gotta kill
them you need your keys
and you gotta come and you gotta kill
one every once in a while yep
that's what it is who are you killing
here no no no no whoa whoa whoa this is
a this is a so I'll kill miles if he
looks bored one more time every time I
look over their mouths like this
is the podcast so boring you can't hold
your head on your mom's got rest and
board faces holy [__] how are we
supposed to be entertaining when miles
is over there trying to kill himself
yeah you need to rest her this is how
boring it is that he needs to rest his
head like this we all have taken at
least 12 [__] drinks the last Celsius
the last one buyer bro we only get miles
Celsius bro yeah and we're gonna get rid
of your chair you're gonna have to stand
the whole [__] podcast I'm tired of
this there's extra gravity when we're
talking so that's how miles feels
we're professional
I need something to throw at this
[__] that won't destroy cameras
that will inflict enough pain that he
has to pay attention to what we're doing
on this goddamn Nerf gun we got to get a
Nerf gun back we need a [__] Nerf gun
back what happened to the nurse yeah
what happened in the Nerf guns yeah they
got lost in the move in the migration
when we were refugees from Brooklyn we
lost everything hmm but we'll get it